هل الاشكاليه ناتجه من ان ظهور مثل هذه
التجارب يعني لا تعتبر الا المشاهير ولا
الفيسبوك ولا ما تعتبر صحافه نتكلم على
الصحافه
بصناعتها الصلبه قائمه على التدريب
والمهاره
والخبرات والمسؤوليه ايضا يعني يتحمل
الصحفي يختلف انه يتحمل المؤسسه الصحفي
المؤسسه الاعلاميه كانت تتحمل مسؤوليه
افعاله وليس حتى فقط نظامنا اذا احنا
نتكلم على غياب صحافه في مكان ما هو نتيجه
الضعف في الاداء الاعلامي وليس نتيجه ظهور
انا اعتقد انه هو كان هناك فراغ شغله
هؤلاء لم تكن مثلا على مستوى المحلي على
الاقل لم تكن الصحافه جانب كثيره مشبعه
ومرضيه ولم تكن تمتلك الادوات ولم يكن
هناك تدريب ولم يكن هناك مهارات معينه
تحدث في مرحله من مراحل كانت الصحافه
ضرورها قدريه مساله قدريه لا خيار امامك
الا انك تقرا صحيفه تنتظر اذا انتظر
يعني ظهرت التواصل وحل الوسائط الاجتماعيه
المختلفه والتقنيات المختلفه
كانت كثير مؤسسات الاعلاميه العربيه وليس
فقط سعوديا متراحله او مطمئنه فلم تستطع
التفاعل بشكل ايجابي او شكل سريع ديناميكي
مثل ما حدث في مؤسسات غربيه التي استشهدت
الخطر وبدات تقوم بعمليه التحول والتحول
لمن يتفق مع هذا الاستثمار المؤسسات
الاعلاميه الكسبانه من المزايا ليش
الخسرانه بالعكس مثلا جريده تطبع عندها
مطاب وشركات توزير ونقل ووراق كان يوم هي
تستطيع ان توصل نفس الماده بنفس الجوده
بنفس القوه وبنفس المثانه بادوات ابسط
وارخص كثير واسرع بسهوله وان تحقق المردود
الاعلام وبدون ما تشتري ورق تسوي
اذا فكرنا فيها حتى اقتصاديا هذا التحورات
التقنيه هي مكسب للصحافه وليست ضدها وليست
تهديدا لكن
الذهنيه انه شعور انه والله انهيار الورق
استاذ صاحبي ستبقل وراء لجيل معين